police guarding the scene in oslo norway
after a deadly shooting during the
city's annual pride festival
a gunman opening fire in the early hours
of saturday outside bars popular with
the lgbt plus community
it's a very dark day in sunny oslo
because we had expected a lively and
enthusiastic parade
through our streets
or people celebrating pride after three
years of pandemics and other standstills
instead we have a dark day where
terror struck oslo this night
those who were there described chaotic
and terrifying scenes
so when i walked into caesar's park
there were a lot of people starting to
run and there was a lot of screaming
then i thought there was a fight out
there so i pulled out but then i heard
that it was a shooting and there was
someone shooting with a submachine gun
police say a 42 year old man with a
history of mental illness
has now been arrested and charged with
committing an act of extreme islamist
terrorism
as for the suspect he is a norwegian
citizen originally from iran he's known
to the police but not for big things
some convictions of minor circumstances
so to speak compared to what we are
facing today
norway's security services have raised
the country's terror alert to its
highest level in response to the
incident and oslo's planned pride parade
has been
cancelled uh the i'd uh
it's tough to experience this we
encourage everyone to stand together
take care of each other we'll be back
later proud visible but right now is not
the time for that
right now a city is reeling
trying to recover from an act of
senseless violence during what should
have been a joyful celebration hannah
thomas peter sky news